do you mind if we talk about
some of the papers do any papers come to
mind that uh have been annotated on the
vermont's library
the the papers that we annotated can be
about completely random topics but
that's part of
what we enjoy as well it forces you to
explore these topics that otherwise
maybe you would never
run into uh and so so the ones that come
to mind that
to me are fairly random but one that i
i really enjoyed learning more about is
um a paper uh written by a mathematician
actually tom apostol
and uh about a uh
a tunnel in a greek island
off the coast of turkey i like this
already random
uh yeah so this uh okay so what's
interesting about this tunnel so this
tunnel
um was built in the sixth century bc
and um and it was built in this
in the island of samos uh which is as i
said off the coast of turkey
and um right they had the city on one
side and the other mountain
and then they had uh a bunch of springs
on the other side and they
they wanted to bring water into the city
um
did building an aqueduct would be pretty
hard because of the way the mountain was
shaped and it would also
you know if they if they were under a
siege like they could just
easily destroy that aqueduct and then
the water wouldn't have any water supply
the city wouldn't have any water supply
and so they decided to build a tunnel
and they decided to try to do it quickly
and so
the they started digging
uh from both ends at the same time
through the mountain right and so like
when you start thinking about this
it's it's a fairly difficult problem and
this is like 6th century bc so
you had very limited access to
you know the mathematical tools that you
had at the time were very limited and so
what this paper is about
is about the story of how they built it
and
about the fact that for about 000 years
kind of the accepted the accepted
explanation of how they built it was
actually wrong
and so this tunnel has been famous for a
while there are a number of historians
that talked about it
since ancient egypt and um and the
method that they described
uh for for building it um is is
uh was just wrong and and so these these
researchers
went there and and were able to figure
figure that out
um and so basically kind of the way that
they thought they had built it was
basically if you can imagine looking at
the mountain from the top
and you have the mountain and then you
have both entrances
um and so what they what they thought
and what this is what the ancient
historians
described is that they effectively tried
to draw
a right angle a right angle triangle
um with the two entrances at each end
of the hypotenuse and the way they did
is like they would
go around the mountain and kind of
walking in a grid fashion
and then you can you can figure out uh
the two sides
of the triangle and then after you have
that triangle you can
effectively draw two smaller triangles
at each entrance that are uh
proportional to that big triangle
uh and then you kind of have arrows
pointing in each way okay
and then you can you you know at least
that these
that you have a line going through the
the mountain that connects both
entrances
the issue with that is like once you
once you go
to this mountain and you start thinking
of doing this
you realize that especially given that
the tools that they had at the time
that your error margin would be too
small you wouldn't be able to do it
uh you you the just the fact
of of trying to to build this triangle
in that fashion
the error would accumulate and you would
end up missing you'd start building
these tunnels and they would miss each
other so the task ultimately is to
figure out like
really perfectly as cl as close as
possible the direction you should be
digging
first of all that it's possible to have
a straight line through
and then what that the direction would
be and then you're trying to infer that
by constructing a right triangle
by doing i i'm not exactly sure about
how to do that rigorously like by
tracing the mountain
by walking along the mountain how to you
said grids yeah
you kind of walk as if you were in a in
a grid and so you you just walk in right
angles
i so right but then you have to walk
really precisely then
exactly you have to use tools to measure
this and the
terrain is probably yeah very much so
this
makes more sense in 2d in 3d it gets
even weirder
so okay gotcha but so this method was
described by like an ancient
egyptian historian i think hero of
alexandria
and um and then for about like yeah for
about 2000 years that's
that's how like that's how we thought
that they had built this this tunnel
um and then uh and yeah and then these
researchers went there and and
found out that actually they they must
have had to to use
other methods and and then in this paper
they describe
these these other methods and of course
they can't know for sure
but there's uh they presented a bunch of
plausible
alternatives uh the one that for me was
is the most plausible is that what they
probably must have done is to
use something that is similar to an iron
sight
on a rifle the way you can line up uh
your rifle
with a target off in the distance by by
having an iron sight
um and uh and they they must have
done something similar to that
effectively would treat
with three sticks and that way they were
able to
line up sticks uh along the side of the
mountain
that were all on the same height and so
that then you could get to the other
side
and you could cut and then you could
draw that line so this for me is the
most plausible
uh way that they might have done that
and they
but then they they they described this
in detail and other possible approaches
in this paper so this is a mathematician
doing this
yeah this is a mathematician that did
this um
which i suppose is the right mindset
instead of skills required to solve an
ancient problem right
yeah yeah mathematicians and engineers
a lot of things because they didn't have
uh computers
or drones or lidar back then or whatever
technology you would
use modern day for civil engineering
yeah and another
fascinating thing is that like you know
after
effectively after the the downfall of
the roman civilization
people didn't build tunnels for about a
thousand years
we go a thousand years without tunnels
and then like only in like in
late middle ages that we start doing
them again but uh but here is the tunnel
like 6th century bc
like incredibly limited mathematics and
they and they build it
in this way um and and and for
and it was a mystery for for a long time
exactly how they did it and
then these mathematicians went there and
and uh
and and basically with no archaeology
kind of background we're able to figure
it out
how do annotations for this paper look
like what is it uh what's a successful
annotation
for paper like this yes so sometimes
you're uh
for this paper um sometimes adding some
more context
uh on on a specific um part like
sometimes they
they mentioned for instance um these
instruments that were common in ancient
greece and in ancient rome
for for building things and uh and and
so
in some of those annotations i described
these instruments in more detail and how
they worked
because sometimes it can be hard to to
visualize these
um then this paper
um i forget exactly when this was
published
i believe maybe maybe the 70s
but then there was further research into
this tunnel and more interesting
other interesting aspects about it i add
those to that paper
as well there's historical context that
i also go into
uh there for instance the fact that as a
as i said that
effectively after the downfall of the
roman empire no tunnels were built like
that's something that i
that i go that i that i added to the
paper as well
yeah so this is so when other people
look at the paper
how did they usually consume the
annotations so they it's like
is there a commenting feature is the i
mean like
this is a really enriching experience
the way you read a paper
what what aspects do you do people
usually talk about that
they value from this so yeah so anybody
can just go on there
and and either add a new annotation or
other
a comment to an existing annotation and
so you can start
a kind of a thread within an existing
annotation
and that's something that happens
relative frequency and then
because i was the original author of the
initial annotation i get pinged
and so oftentimes i'll go back and and
and add on to to that thread
how did you pick the paper i mean first
of all this whole
process is really exciting i'm gonna
especially after this conversation i'm
gonna
make sure i participate much more
actively
on papers that i know a lot about and on
paper that i know nothing about actually
both when i say the paper
i would love to i also i mean i i
realized that uh
there's a like it's an opportunity for
people like me
to publicly annotate a paper
like or do an ama around the paper
like yeah exactly but yeah but like be
um be in the conversation about a paper
it's like a place to
have a conversation about an idea you
could the other way to do it that's much
more ad hoc is on twitter
right but this is more like formal and
you could actually probably integrate
the two
they have a conversation about the
conversation so the twitter
is the conversation about a conversation
and the main conversation is in the
space of annotations
there's an interesting effect that we we
see sometimes with the annotations on
our papers is that
a lot of people especially if we the
annotations are really well done
people sometimes are afraid of adding
more annotations because they see that
as a kind of a finished work
yes and so they they don't want to
pollute that or
and especially if it's like a silly
question this is i don't think
that's good i think you know we should
as much as possible try to lower the
barrier for someone to jump in and ask
questions i think it only on
like most of the times it adds value but
it's some feedback that we got from
users and and readers um
i'm not exactly sure how to to kind of
fight that but um well i think i
i think if i serve as an inspiration
in any way is by asking a lot of dumb
questions
and saying a bunch of dumb [ __ ] all the
time and hopefully that inspires the
rest of
uh other folks to do the same because
that's the only
way to knowledge i think is to be
willing to ask the dumb questions
you